all right and we all love the last word
with Lord kindly know any Bartis fresh
on that Friday morning campfire ready to
talk a lot of destiny and maybe some
other things what is going on abates how
you doing sir man it has been quite a
week this morning mm-hmm
has honestly been a little bit of a slow
start just gonna get in the ball rolling
but this week has been interesting so I
actually beat two different games this
week which we got a preview stream we
got a lot going on so for me I played
finished up neo to finally finish the
final boss everything so though but
great honestly like at level one
I haven't eaten somewhere in that realm
level ha whatever to be honest like
eating that game on Normal difficulty
it's not to the level of a look at Nier
automata where it's like multiple
endings it's more that like the game
opens up and gets even deeper like you
now go like New Game+ like I've been
watching a couple videos to see like
people mention New Game+ being cool like
you there's a whole crafting system in
there and then like kind of using soul
Coors infusions and different things
that doesn't even start until you beat
it for the first time or you may as well
not so like your gear you can get a new
tier of gear in the gym plus you can get
like a new set of stats on there and you
can go through and then potentially what
I've heard and so I guess what they did
before because I didn't track neo one as
much mm-hmm like each DLC is gonna
introduce like a newer difficulty in
newer levels of things so it's like just
the base run through the game that
already kicked my butt enough he's like
what apparently they say they're just
getting started
okay okay salute ban me so what would
you ranked as far as a difficulty
comparison to like a second row
Sakura so weird cuz it's like it's so
much about the pairing yeah I mean you
have to like peri-peri like you got to
learn the rhythm of the boss in a
different way but it's like you gotta be
up on the boss to actually knock him
down because if you guys like dodge the
entire time and take swings it's such a
so much of a longer fight than it should
be okay so it's a different combat style
I mean you got blood-borne which is like
the one that broke me honestly I really
hope crossing my fingers blood-borne
comes to like PC or 60 frames or
whatever like there's a refresh voice
cuz I want to play it again I'm gonna
say oh I'm gonna say without spoiling
too much I'm hearing strong Inklings
that your dream will come true
I mean I've heard the same thing since
I've been like kind of so that seems
like it's like okay we got we got hopes
of that one oh yeah and I would
definitely jump on it again because that
was like my first Souls like I didn't
play like souls one I didn't play demon
and play Souls - I played blood-borne
I've playing Star Wars I've played
second row I've played in Dark Souls 3 I
don't think there's anything else
probably at 1 or 2 oh there's a neo 1
neo one it's up there the like from neo
1 to neo 2 it's a step up across the
board don't know just overall like for
me to put my words together in a review
would take a little while you can also
see new game+ I'm honestly just getting
started and the funny thing is like I
went mostly into kind of a magic stat
build cuz that's the one that helped the
weapon I was using which was the switch
clave it's kind of like a scythe like a
Grim Reaper scythe and then I mostly
just went for health but there's like
completely different builds of like
print like throwables like ninja stars
and stuff that you can like dive into on
that one
there's swords there's like double
hatchets double swords a giant Adachi
like two-handed thing the size of me
there's like seven different weapon
types I didn't even play with I played
with one because I just focused on that
you were stuck with your dad father this
is not a dad bod thank you there's no
there's no dad bonding
I'm gonna be honest there's no dead body
guy here so you better not say that I
mean you can go ahead and pick up the
switch clave and see if it's a dad
bought weapon so I'll see how your
progress through the game goes I'll
leave all those difficult stressful
games to you man those are amazing to
watch dream I admit I do not have the
mental stamina nor do I have the
patience anymore but I will say this let
me shout out myself hold on I'm a big
turn-based guy but we had by phone I
know he's he's huge our turn base he's
an ex-con guy like me so I picked up all
gears tactics OPC I've been rocking that
I got that finish man let me tell you
that game is difficult towards the end
it that game pushes limits like for
people who come from the Xbox universe I
would say Escom to war of the chosen
probably one of the hardest this could
rival it but I will say this the boss
fights and the production value in this
game are tremendous and this is Unreal
Engine 4 so I'm more already hype at
what 4 is doing right now we already
send 5 with the PlayStation 5 devil no
salute the gears tactics but only
nitpick would be they they have side
missions that are not really side
missions they're mandatory missions
before you can advance story and those
get a little repetitive what the game is
it's a prequel in in the gears of your
war universe with a legit story with um
kpop it's really and I like him as a
character it's really good so I got that
done I got mortal kombat after NAFTA I'm
getting a lot done when I am playing
that's the I'm just noticing this way
when I didn't play destiny I am the most
productive hardcore gamer so all the
guys that always like clown me on gamers
core stuff let it be known that's these
just that amazing that you don't say if
I was to really focus and go after you
got hey I could do it so shout the R and
outdoors although the game is called
people who usually give me crap because
I'm always evil on destiny but yeah it's
been a fun little two weeks you know I'm
saying just to kind of refresh my
batteries I've been checking in I've
been looking at your Twitter you know
you've been taking these illustrious
photos that you we have in the back
we'll get to that in a minute yeah yeah
so it's oh shout out to law real mental
what I think it a new XCOM
yes I have it I tried it out um chimera
squad it's good it's just different I
kind of look at it as a side story in
the universe I'm not saying this is bad
it's just that for whatever reason gears
tactics grabbed me first so it's in my
pecking order of like it move down a
spot cuz Mortal Kombat here's one kind
of fan I love the narrative so I had to
beat the DLC which continues the story
and cares tactics looked amazing had to
get that done so I say I will do
probably if I could sneak in chimera
after last of us come to a Last of Us
right now it trying to stick as much as
I can before that comes and then yes
that he's definitely getting started on
table yeah June 19th
mmm that's why for me I didn't third
Final Fantasy 7 remake which is on my
backlog for sure cuz that's just so good
I've heard but I don't want to rush that
thing I haven't played it before so I
really want to like take it all in and
enjoy rush it you're smart shoutout to
you for play it inside yes so that was
the other one I played that in one night
now if you guys that haven't heard of
insight or limbo Oh some of you may have
I do not play dead awesome studio limbo
I played first and I like I got it on
like an iPad and this is what this
stupid this is what this little game
date on an iPad I was in a middle seat
on flight home about a two and a half
hour flight and I start playing this
thing on my iPad it's it's kind of black
and white kind of grayscale you do mean
it's not too great like inside would
have been a bit graphic for a plane yeah
um but it still got a couple gruesome
you know it's platforming and puzzles
and a little bit of kind of horror ish
like a [ __ ] platformer puzzler and
we're working through and by the time
this flight is done the people on either
side of me are like both looking in and
kind of giving me confidence all the for
the puzzles and stuff like that we don't
finish it on the flight I literally get
home from the flight and the first thing
I do is lay down on the bed and finish
this damn game on the iPad before
anything else happens so so that was
limbo played that the first time and for
the longest time my new insight was out
it's been out four years at this Roy
Hobbs so proud of you it's and I've
wanted to play it forever and I was just
like I finished up neo twos like first
playthrough and it's like what do I play
and then I was going through just like
kind of back
and I remember those like it's still my
origin axis and I've got a couple things
on there mm-hmm and it's like and I was
like and I was like I could knock it out
in one stream and I look him like it's
about four hours and was waiting for my
wife to get done with a call so I
started like nine and I was like it's
gonna be kind of a late night but I
technically don't have to get up early
so we started mm-hmm
I will say the way that game with zero
words zero dialogue zero text you the
environmental storytelling the sound
design the lack of music or when you add
music the animations that they did it
was so good so late and I'm not gonna
give spoilers away the lake the
climactic like final piece and that one
the whole you know nuts absolutely like
what in the hell is my inventory like
you could in it's like a weird book that
you could interpret like 12 different
ways and there's a lot of people that
have theories about it but I will say
the way they did the animation for final
thing big yes like when you're working
on like puzzles and moving things around
in said and I'm not spoiling it cuz you
would I do it's just crazy you can toss
be a this game is such a masterpiece
you gotta for anything else so like it's
if you have like four or five like I did
in about three and a half hours I was
like kind of mate I had a pretty good
clip through the puzzles and stopped it
a couple points but says about four or
four and a half hours if you want to do
it all and there's a couple secrets I
could go back through and find which you
can hop to missions and get but overall
dude the lake I was playing through half
the people in the stream were probably
watching you play through it and there
were just points it was like it was dead
silence it was like all I heard was the
like the character just breathing and
you're looking and in there and then
there's no and then you hear still like
music pick up yo what's gonna happen and
just the way it was it was such a well
done well I don't let's a little game
like it's an indie but honestly like an
indie studio for like set free for like
a fifth game people would probably kill
to make one out good
much like their second game yeah dude
they are geniuses I mean date like I
said I'm so glad you played that game
that's my one of my little smaller indie
masterpieces on it it got I was so happy
I got critical acclaim and what a lot of
Game Awards - so salute that it's what
you said about the plane story
it's the perfect game to show someone
who's not a gamer
I've won people over on that game who
are not gamers and they sit there and
they like wait a minute alright what if
you move over there and try this and
they're over my shoulder does that got
it they it's amazing
atmospheric storytelling just a good I
won't I will say this though did you
last i don't you be talking along on the
all the games we play outside that's
okay oh I wonder as you did you do the
secret ending yet no I haven't any
please do you cannot talk to me yet
until you do that it is mandatory but
you got to get some special items on
each level do that and then you get and
it's one of the great discussion pieces
in what are we interpret it happening it
is I'll be we get philosophical with
that that's how it's good you know say
so salute though play this video
getting cultured look at the culture it
right now proud of you
thanks not trying to take that phrase
I love it yeah this other thing that we
like uh so the world of destiny sorry
guys for the tangent but it's been you
know kind of an off week and we'll get
into why there might be a little more
time to have off weeks but if you guys
are watching the video you can obviously
see the background if you're in the
audio there's a picture of what looks to
be a sunrise and it's like I pulled the
screenshot from destiny and for those of
you guys that haven't been paying
attention still be like hey I got my
fill winters I'm done until I hear
what's coming next season mmm I've been
staring into the Sun at noon in this
damn game four days in a row yes you
have so my whole thing when it started
was I was like okay we have two weeks
left in the season it was this was on
Tuesday like for recent two weeks left
in the season I was like all right in my
head this is what I had kept saying on
Twitter and to everybody else this is
like my claim of like question I was
like okay so on the 26th we're going to
have something happen at the Almighty
that'll give that a little breathing
room that thing's gonna wrap up then you
be like hey you got one more week and
the next week coming up a week before
the season starts as they've done in
previous seasons one week before Tuesday
we'll get this like ten second teaser
hey tune in tomorrow at this time oh
yeah Trey oh yeah Wednesday Wednesday
the trailer would come we'd all talk all
about that and everything like that
would happen and the season would launch
much to my dismay log in on Tuesday and
we're like nothing yeah like freaking
nothing and then I'm like watching
Twitter and somebody's like you can see
the almighty in the Sun I'm like BS and
then at first didn't believe it and then
you go in the tower and it seems it like
noon in the towers like sunset they have
to like wait like 15 minutes for the
damn Sun to come back up so I've been
staring at these mountains in the
background way too much as well so
finally I'm like okay so some people
look you squint really hard or some
people dislike fuzzy image on a TV like
pixelated monitor and they're like hey
you can see it and I'm like seriously so
I'm looking at it and I'm trying to and
I'm like maybe I can maybe I can I'm
like all right so let me turn my
resolution on my game as high as I can
render resolution even higher every
video settings
to the max and I'm like right let me
take a screenshot and I plot that
screenshot over into Photoshop and all I
did is if you guys know Photoshop this
will make perfect sense but you can have
blending layers where two different
layers kind of like blend together or if
you see like overlays or you'll see how
somebody put like text but kind of looks
like the background image there's
certain ways to like blend images
together and once called multiply and I
couldn't probably define it perfectly
right now but as I add copies and copies
of multiply it kind of would basically
make things contrast more it would make
the image of the Almighty on the Sun
just pop perfectly it looks like just a
perfect black silhouette on the Sun I'm
like okay they're not lying like that as
it is absolutely for real that the
Almighty has just plopped out there in
the sky box sitting sitting in front of
the Sun and between us and the Sun and I
posted that on Twitter it was a popular
picture apparently bro you don't broke
Twitter now you don't got popular no you
got hot but I mean it did just a little
bit of like the lit tiniest little bit
of Photoshop cuz everybody's like trying
to take like iPhone images on their TV
and stuff like that and people are
looking at it and I'm just like let me
just change it one thing and I put it
like a 60 second video out there showing
like here's the image I'm doing nothing
I'm literally just copying multiply
layers and you can see it pop perfectly
and then I just zoom in so it's like I'm
not messing with it so I was like I've
got a little bit of traction so would
you you nailed it you know the money
mm-hmm though the almighty is in the
skybox yeah we are your thoughts about
that as it hasn't moved in three days
yeah it hasn't moved on you know listen
you know we're getting to I want to get
into an insert was based on what the 12
is but our again what I'm gonna say
probably kind of links to that and it
just yeah it was interesting that it
really didn't progress much and we
didn't get this ominous thing that I
thought we was going to get like
hovering looming over you know I'm
saying so it's interesting and based on
what we're about to talk about what they
try what they're about to talk about I
definitely have some theories as to
why it is in the state it is in but I'm
gonna hold that until we read what we
gotta read Oh for basic astronomy math
we're back to this again by the way I
was like okay so I was talking with chat
and it was like streaming and trying to
figure out I was like okay so how far
away is this because somebody had
mentioned at one point on Twitter
somebody was like leh if we can see it
from our atmosphere it should like crash
in in like hours once at the point we
see it from the distance that it's got a
travel and it's like okay so we got to
do the math oh those for me tonight
stuff about what we doing well no okay
see it late
obviously the planets orbit around the
Sun so you could be on one side or the
other so distances I know is gonna be
the same but the average distance that
mercury is from Earth is 48 million
miles away it's a long ways now for
reference the moon from Earth is about
250,000 miles away we're talking
forty-eight million miles 250,000 miles
right now the seasons roughly 90 days
mm-hmm
ballparking basic numbers here hmm
so if you say hey we start the season in
the almighty bad things supposed to be
traveling towards Earth right if that's
the case on average it needs to travel
500 thousand miles today it needs to
travel twice our distance from the earth
to the moon every day it needs to travel
twice that in a day to make it here now
if there's like space and acceleration
it should instance be like gaining speed
the entire time so the idea that it's
not moving in the game for math sake
usually when bundage is like really all
over this stuff is the point where I'm
like all right it's a video game and I
have to stop but like if it's parked out
there it's not functioning as it should
be is all I'm saying this so I know
that's nerdy nerdy ass math or this is
this is very adorable what you're doing
right now I'm variable this is like
you've touching my heart with your
passion for this lack of content that we
have that you are breaking this down to
the subatomic
like you are there this is just you are
so oh like you just warm in my heart
brother it we have gotten to this point
where there is nothing going on in this
game where we are breaking this thing
down you got my man he's in his bag
right look avere he's doing this big
right bad he spies one of the best but
man we need some content for youi we
need some content for youi right this is
what we talked about other games for
like 15 minutes but I can only stare
into the Sun so long crazy looking at
the Sun for too long it has actually
damaged my eyeballs and my brain and I
am crazy
no like usually like I give Bungie
credit because typically they have like
you know cool things there was make sure
Caitlyn they've got like Eris morn and
there's literally a centaur which is
like an object out in our solar system
called Eris and it's like they have all
of these things that they reference very
well and then I'm sitting there looking
at a almighty which didn't move over the
course of the three days and the main
reason is if it did start like showing
up on Tuesday this week right I honestly
think even if it didn't like travel by
math because my math like if we saw it
like at the Sun it probably should have
crashed into Earth like 12 hours later
but if it did at least just like get
bigger every day yeah like over the
course of the week this thing's like you
know starting to get pretty substantial
and then on Tuesday everything hits
maybe we'll see well talk about that but
I would love to have seen it just change
in size everybody's like this is bad
it's it's again just I'd love it that to
get in there cuz like right looking at
the Sun and seeing the damn thing the
same size every day is like you know
what I wouldn't update on this thing
because it should I not be floating out
there you know what should have happened
something similar to um what was it what
was the wack seasonal they did something
good though in a way sees it knows what
was shadow keeps accompanying a company
oh yeah when remember when they were
building the structure for the for the
what was it the gate the walk
yeah like member each day we will oh no
okay like that like something mimicking
that in reference to you know this this
thing coming and and that would have
been you know really cool acceptable and
stuff like that and yeah I mean that it
is surprising and I can't want to say
what it's a bad I can't say it without
respectfully we haven't gotten to the
table yet but oh it is definitely
disappointing as to you know why that
that hasn't happened but you know what
not to press car yet construction was
weekly you know saying but again you
know we've know this thing has been
compact but it this way they've been
treating the Doritos with the energy
that the almighty technically should
also have yeah right but we login we
like all Rasputin here come to read all
man is it's in here then they imposing
like really if you look at it
this season's content that the main
theme really hasn't been stressed
outside of us building the towers right
will you come into the planet you see
the towers get higher okay he's getting
that full strength but the almighty like
even if we would have had like a little
cinematic over tenten tenten like a
shark looks like it's like halfway
through the season just like it's flying
like where is it mission to Venus or
something just like have it go just
something out there Mila Compton just
like a little thing is a reminder by the
way this thing's still going like it's
been look we're just season frenzy like
day one almighty Zavala all this stuff
yeah nothing like nothing
week 11 there almost feels like that
like they got their threats mixed the
threats got twisty like the season told
us the threat was this but then we see
it's this and we forgot about Almighty
already and then the almighty was like
who cares
ya know Maddie's upset now I'm all I
could look you was so worried about
ships I'm gonna take my time you'll get
me in you some pic when when I'm good
and ready
did you see you got your Guardian games
to celebrate through you're gonna go do
this quest that's hitting bugged you got
public events to do
man absolutely absolutely man so yeah
staring into the Sun will probably
continue I don't know if it matters but
Bailey said I tend to be around my
computer so we will see
sounds good hopefully we get some man we
need something what is that
this is will get into the tois but it's
late it has been a very like when you
think back on the season like if I did a
video cuz like dados done too and it's
like I'm honestly like a review on this
season would be for one a pretty rough
account first off but on the other side
like what caught somebody was like what
content did we get in PvE stock entities
like no no like for PvE content the we
actually like got that we're like we
have a public event in the same space we
have lost sectors in the same space we
had bunker clear outs which are like
baby lost sectors but like wheeze
haven't got like a Sun Dial activity we
haven't we haven't had anything for like
six months like we haven't seen a new
activity in about six months and that's
weird
yeah I was like and that's why the
people are like gonna rate season of the
worthy would be like where's it rate and
people are like the bottom of whatever
list you're gonna put it on the bottom
it's just funny because of the name of
this season I think it's the is the name
of this season didn't help it did not
help but oh yeah man it is it is really
even when I try to be like okay there's
got to be something right and even when
I did felt winters which thank you gonna
have to get abused by you anymore I have
but um you know even now it's like okay
you know cool but um did you like the
lower story that you got yes yes I like
the lore can we are we full spoiler free
oh yeah no we are glad our tongues off
last year shut up Teddy Teddy was
awesome you know shout out to you you
guys are awesome but not smaller that
like you guys do it was really good I
love the deception I love you know the
tyrant you know he's Rasputin is kind of
messed up man you know say like he's so
basically yet you know feldman winter
living amongst us and
no sir poorly run it running back but
you know obviously the light and there
is you know thing for humans changed now
what's cool is the lore on the shaadi
was really cool because you see him I
believe he's talking to the Lord timber
and it was like keeping the secret of
like what you actually are the fell
winter is actually part of he's part you
know human I mean part Guardian part
Rasputin thing you know kind of thing
and just to find out that you know the
iron Lords the deceiver was Rasputin man
damn damn
but um I love the emotional side you
know um apparently obviously they have
lists
respira does have some regret obviously
and then um you know but the only thing
I will say is this being that he was
part rasputin's I'm just surprised that
he can't and he was an XO he's kind of
mechanical in nature almost all around
so I'm like well why can't he be back
maybe it's a question for byph you know
I'm just curious you know I know Sivir
kills the arm you know can kill your
ghosts and all that stuff too but just
for the lore guys I was just curious um
you know what that whole I just curious
did why he can't be brought back
especially being that he was part of
recipe I think that part of him Connor
can print do a comeback but I guess you
know they just want to give us some
context to fell winter the whole story
behind the lie because the be honest I
thought from winters largest man fell
winter himself was a liar but the
reality is the lie is who he was who he
really was that you know about about his
mission his initial mission and stuff
like that so it was a good piece of law
I really enjoyed it I have to say you
know if I'll yo Daniels do it was like
follows copy and say it was cut and
paste not copy and paste they did a row
like the difference there so how like
that no that was kind of cool about Phil
winter you got to see the lake I mean
the fact that you know it's like ends
and the tyrant wept and you're like yeah
rasputin big AI weepy question mark like
is there an emotional piece to like the
fact of what he did and potentially
killed his Sutton per se or however you
want to reference him I was like it's it
was a deep story for what was
potentially like an AI type moment
you're like yes hmm
and then what do you think of the room
when you got down there I was pretty
cool I like that old bunker I love to
join the little you know the little
robot crib didn't it it was cool I
really I really enjoy it man I thought
it was a nice little story I loved
listen one thing I will say is terrible
as this season is um in general one
thing about the season format that I
have like this they've least attempted
story moments and each season there's
been a story moment at least try not all
the time they knock it out but you know
that one was a nice little bit you know
I'm saying that was cool and I like
these kind of bits but um as far as
connective tissue bits we still still
got work to do you know yeah it's like I
was talking to like my stream too and I
was just like wow I'm like I was
honestly wondering like how is these
stories connected see had like season of
the undying and then like as we were
messing with the portal than the portal
kind of broke time and then all of a
sudden Osiris is over here with the
sundial which you don't just like make
it a day but then apparently the sundial
is like oh the cabal they want to try
and fix time so whatever red leaves were
left or trying to be like hey let's
reverse this back and try this again and
then we brought Saint back Saints parked
on the tower
we went from dawn to worthy because hey
the sundial didn't happen so the backup
for the sundial again the red lesion for
like the seventh time go to the almighty
yeah and they're like hey let's point
this thing at the last city is a futile
effort to kamikaze the ship in the
velocity are we done with the red Legion
at least yeah I need to be done with I'm
done
I was all about cabal when um d2 started
because I've always liked a ball because
they'd I feel I didn't get represented
enough in d1 but I am kobold
and right now it's like if I need if it
ain't Calais I wanna see how was he you
know saying like I'm being shout to bite
though he bore his daughter or whatever
yeah
when wife came on and he talked about
the daughter you know and it that that
intrigued me cuz I do like the female
caval flow you know saying that would be
kind of cool like hola but um for right
now you know let's just put it this way
you know they are in dire need of the
new race they are in dire need of like
we have Cana you know it also exhausted
but we haven't had enough break between
the races that's where a new one should
come in you know I'm Sam
but um yeah dad on what you bro like I
remember when uh d2 came I was like
y'all cabal rate that was so open if I
like super hype and then that has been
detuning there's been you gonna get this
kebab you gonna lose you go you go go
back you go do four raids on Leviathan
plan apartment to a to be like I'm good
good you're gone you won't get this you
gonna get this menagerie you go get all
Escobar's oh by the way they they back
here company we don't they gonna go
Charlie but you way like that you try to
stop us and d2 at the beginning the
story so now we're gonna message the Sun
down now oh you know what we didn't like
that so now the Cabal go mess with the
almighty like the Cabal enough enough
cabal we get it we you don't like the
guardians we got it let's move on it's
related to don't get me wrong dole
menagerie fire that's the guy I'm not
really like the game honestly measure II
menage Rick menagerie the menagerie late
the precedent that that set yeah it is
broke it broke
like everybody like it was a lot of fun
then you had the multiple rewards then
started just stripping stuff away and we
were from that to vex offensive no no I
got a little bit better this season it's
like since then man
mmm-hmm it was like drifter to menagerie
and season of opulence like the contrast
of those two seasons one is obviously
what a lot of us are hoping is something
next season but in the fall but like
just the contrast we're like such a load
to a high and then it's just been kind
of down saying like yeah and I will say
this about the right you know what I
feel I feel like I guess lore wise again
body for knows best you know we said how
the houses are scattered and what I
would ever know what have fun yeah for
fallen I feel like they need a big bad
like falling these like a new big bad to
come in and you know what I'm saying
like I feel like everybody of the other
races got a lot of big especially to
hide like the hive or the king of we are
scared of them they got stuff cooking
and we got Sabbath old we still got
things to deal with them right but it's
like I feel like the fallen I'm besides
even even scored you to pass you know
that rate you know the boss it we know
the Metal Gear boss you know I just
don't feel like I've really connected
with their but even one of my favorite
raids which is ratted a machine axis
didn't have a personality to the realest
dope but don't like he wasn't built up
your he wasn't I'm saying like living up
the story build right yeah the fall
India to fall in have fun it's ever like
they need like a true or exceed guy
that's like look I'm gonna bring these
house a again I don't like they're not
going they're all separated these little
houses they're like the I know I mean
they're the scavengers of the universe
they're not powerful like the Cabal the
war in means they're they're trained to
survive they're scattered there's yeah
you're right you're right I just feel
like they almost need a dominus goal arc
in the sense of Dominus girl wants to
know why we were chosen right the Fallen
had the light before us right and they
got rejected now by the trailer for
whatever reason right so it I feel like
they needed ominous going be like why
did you chose you know they like they
need don't worry though like honestly
the better I like what I see with the
Fallen potentially as I think
plug the art not byph later if mythrax
comes in and somehow please read them to
be an ally right right so like if that
happens in us like either joining forces
they're fighting with us we're out there
on like patrol missions or something
like that and they're like they're the
guards in front of the tower or the city
like if there's a point where we grow we
there
I mean potentially Calais is like
playing games with us he may be an ally
ish we'll see I don't know of course
people probably know that deeper but
like potentially fallen would be one of
those especially on our scale they don't
have like the big towering crazy vex lay
story longer than us like the Fallen are
more on our level so it's like for us to
work with them at some point if there
can be this like loved what you know
glue between Hondo Chris crystals on it
though a new friend has a rat verax
would be awesome what judge me who would
want to hear that prisoner over the
voice everybody wants a very straight
you would love that judgment a new
friend has arrived what I love these sub
barracks made out just to hear his voice
prison of elders oh I could listen to
that all day that would be yeah we kind
of find is that your ASMR I'm going for
it I'm going for yeah he's got some
stories that yeah you say what the death
is just post on Twitter oh he part so so
should we check Twitter yeah hold on do
they did they do something we have some
more to talk about
oh hold on uh there's an audio clip it
looks like oh oh oh we got we got we got
audio destiny the game lets it slip I'm
gonna try I'm uh trying to myself to
excuse me no it does this live y'all
live broadcasting you get this
two minutes yeah they just post a sudden
it's going crazy can you hear it and you
not MIT can you not talk don't talk is
that that hard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bro that was nothing I'm sorry that I've
commanded I'm talking there was nothing
to say can you not talk for one minute
and 13 seconds that's all I'm asking
oh it was so low there's nothing to hear
like I was just like my missus I thought
some was wrong with my audio I'm like
kid he's here something that I'm not
hearing cuz I just heard that's all it
is that's I was waiting to see if
something happened it's just like kind
of slow faint like little mechanical
noises and clicking in this kind of just
like like kind of like almost this is
where we at right now y'all just put it
in Twitter if you guys are looking or
just put the link in there guys if you
want to know all right yeah aw all right
listen this is yesterday I was they said
watch their damn Twitter so they
apparently meant it brah that was that
what the hell is that
what was that no no no no no that was a
beam but was dead again like this is
okay so perfect timing Bungie thanks for
dropping a bomb for our satellite 57 in
the morning salut salut so we gotta this
week at buns yes we give ASMR mm-hmm
audio look Oh somebody's like the audio
does it look like a pyramid
pyramid shape yeah the pyramid shape in
the like audio graph but it's a pyramid
mm-hmm image in there okay dude are you
looking at it right now uh but I didn't
see an image I just know I just heard
audio ever do you sit like okay so it's
a video okay
and it shows like what would look be
like kind of an audio like linear bar
graph of what it looks like but there's
a big kind of angular looking triangle
in the middle of that thing I had no
image of my my splash screen I literally
had a black screen with just audio and
creepy sound that's all I had so there's
a little image in the background so try
and go back to it or refresh it or
something like that maybe oh I got to
blow it up okay it it's a pyramid so
pyramids are coming it's the erie
pyramids here they are okay I get what
they try to do nah man not a study I is
to this is this is the fake deepness
that I'm talking about right now
this is not it this is that it then I
shouldn't tune in to Twitter why isn't
this in the game no no no this I can't
this is not this is I can't get my pass
for this someone on Twitter by the way
this is not it this is a weird podcast
this morning by the way cuz for you guys
that don't that don't yeah well we don't
normally see like destiny things live at
Friday morning somebody was like sounds
like it's time to go run garden of
salvation see if anything's changed
politest he's like I doubt it but yeah
you you go do that somebody go do that
for me let me know uh lorb it's outside
the game oh boy how I thought we would
do it this a do it and then oh come on
they do their augmented reality games
and crap like in the real world so but
yeah Paris Seto one two three four says
it's the audio file from the end of
garden of salvation with the statue
that's what somebody's saying
potentially this is what I call fake
deepness this is the epitome of fake
deepness of overthinking stuff that oh
this guy this is the type of content I
don't want to see with it like Oh
better oh my god yeah yeah yeah Prescott
don't let your brother like traumatic
this is not something I don't know I
don't know if he was referencing this
dramatic if I'm coming at you me to come
at you if you're not roasted it but man
man man man what can I say this season
cannot be over fast enough yeah like I
will I mean okay so
this would get bungy drops and Diedre it
so what I want to do is read this to you
guys and then we're gonna talk because
I've seen opinions thoughts of what this
could imply and I don't have a better
way to phrase this stuff because deej is
the master of saying words and yet
telling you nothing mm-hmm and I mean
that respectfully because if you said a
PR state and people are like what about
this he's like well let me tell you
these 20 things that don't answer your
question he's awesome at that which is
amazing to watch but he took over the 12
this week and he said this week a bungee
we look to the sky
ever since the season began the almighty
has been hurling through space on its
collision course with earth which we
forgot about most of us until it got
reminded the Cabal are not known for
their graceful defeats every day we
spend preparing our long-lost Seraph to
mount a response that derelict destroyer
Rockets ever closer to our home spelling
certain doom for the city Rasputin is at
full power which I have a question about
that we'll come back to first mmm-hmm
we're as ready as we'll ever be again
you think you guys know where I'm going
now eclipsing her own Sun is a stark
reminder that a great threat approaches
eyes up
what's so okay we'll do this in pieces
at full power were as ready wolves ever
be why is it not been blasted out of the
sky
why have we not fired on unify yeah
that's a good point it's that's that's a
my first question valid yeah somebody's
like is it a butt dial from the pier
somebody Joe the pyramid butt down
that's yes oh good anyway but like that
the line that it says he's at full power
we did the nine million we did the fell
winter thing he's ready I can see it
that means we have satellites we shot up
from Earth we shot up for the moon by
the way this is another weird question
the earth of the moon okay
why was the other planet not Mars
because that's the one that's closest to
Earth that would help with like
triangulation and satellites and firing
as opposed to IO which is so much
farther away past the asteroid belt by
Jupiter yet we shoot our satellites up
from there mm-hmm I so far away cuz it's
coming from mercury it's coming from the
other direction
I am slated the astronomy part of my
head which I'm not an astronomer but
still just my space knowledge is like
breaking you know it's gotta continue
happy good to you what's next
question mark destiny has been a shared
pastime for a long enough now to have
established some strong traditions each
year we spend in service of the
guardians we can mark our calendars by
the next development milestones will
reach and/or the next event will attend
spent attend to spread the news some of
us have had the remarkable privilege to
travel to the world to meet some of you
find people to talk about what comes
next
this year finds us all in a scenario
that puts us all very far away from
business as usual basically all fights
original flight surgeon ating from the
tower are grounded development of
destiny to continues only we're working
from the safety of our homes we have
exciting news to share with you about
our plans but it won't happen at some
fancy convention under hot lights
instead we'll use the internet if you
are so if you're familiar with the
rituals and cycles that mark a year in
the life of a guardian you must be
curious as to win we'll begin a
conversation about what is next we can't
put a date on that just yet but we will
very soon that's a promise
we know you're hungry for the
and were just as eager to deliver as
just as eager to deliver it
keep your eyes trained on bungees
twitter for updates
obviously this morning prime freaking
example hey whatever it means nobody
knows but we're trading on it now mmm
will stream our announcements in the
usual places you'll learn about the new
season of destiny too at the same time
that we'll talk about the next chapter
in this story that will we have been
that has been unfolding all year long I
want to read that again because that's
an important line you'll learn about the
next season of destiny too at the same
time that we talk about the next chapter
in this story that has been unfolding
all year long final peace deep-diving
now it's justin truman one of the
production directors i said in recent
editions of this week a Bungie cue from
directors in the community on what we
should talk about our tension has been
focused on your feedback our words are
pointed towards what we plan to do to
bring the game into alignment with what
you've been talking about they do a
recap of the things that they've
mentioned in previous swabs like 4:23
security cheaters what we're doing about
them for 30 seasons in year for reducing
FOMO improving bounties 5 7 or Ward's
the ever verse transmog 5:14 max levels
our max power level season heaven
redacted in Graham 3 load perks in the
ever confusing world loop pool all of
that has been covered in the previous
like 5 weeks we covered a lot of ground
and while we are going to continue to
provide updates each week to topics you
care about we want to shift our focus in
the coming weeks we've said a lot about
changes coming in year 4 but we haven't
talked about how year 4 begins very soon
will do just that
I kicked off this series of deep dives
with some promises but I want to end the
series on a more personal note being
able to being unable to go to the office
trying to figure out how to keep
building the game we love from our
laptops and our couches has me thinking
a lot about commitment video game
development is messy evolving destiny
too in an open transparent way involves
showing and shipping plenty of missteps
along with the improvements but it
continues to be worth it every step of
this way because I can honestly say this
is the most welcoming passionate
community that I have ever encountered
in any game which we could
and the final important lines coming up
we're committed to this game to staying
transparent about our plans into this
relationship we have with our community
the reason we started on this journey
ten years ago haven't changed we're
committed to building a world anyone can
be a part of where everyone can feel
powerful and where you might reconnect
with old friends and make some new ones
so we look forward to continuing this
conversation and continuing to evolve
destiny together and in 12 days we can't
wait to show you more of what we've been
working on Stace a month our Guardians
and generous is just patch notes on
Twitch prime and all that stuff so
that's the big old cryptic 12 of all
twubs yes very very cryptic all right I
talked for a while you go yeah and
listen arm you know when I got this one
you know obviously me and you you know
messaged offline just say what was our
feeling right well what we feeling when
we read this and you know to me this is
what I gather out of it um very the word
the first word that came to my mind was
cryptic right um we are we are kind of
talking about what's going on in the
world we're talking about how that's
affected the studio or violet we're
talking about all the things that we've
told you with these kind of mini
director cuts and destiny team guys on
each level of the game do great stuff
great mole for the most part
transparency stuff - the world loop pool
I think it's the only one we added a
little question like okay this one
didn't make sense a little bit we need
more clarity but for the most while all
this has been great and like you said as
we started to show he we are in a
cadence this is a tradition for us right
the two weeks before the season ends
there is a cadence that we are as
destiny fans we are used to right the
first week is either hey tune into the
stream tune into the whatever we're
gonna talk about this or hey tune in
next week because this game changing
event is gonna happen and lead us into
boom and we're gonna talk about it so
this there's no hard and fast date
there's no hard and fast date as to
where
season of the whatever it is that's
going to be better than the worthy I'm
gonna give that I'm gonna put that out
there do whatever it is it's gonna be
better than worthy other than that pause
that high but it's gonna be better
that's what I'm rolling away you know
I'm saying so to me you know we all know
the pyramids are coming we don't know
how soon we figured this is the
precursor to September which Luke Smith
affectionately says we are not prepared
so ultimately you know it's got to be
the at least at minimum and appetizer
right so when I read this and shut up
homeboy his name is this Justin Justin
Sherman yes you know what I read it's
from Justin the vibe I get when I got a
comment I'm gonna bring about two guys I
got a question about I got is that this
is a fluid situation I don't get the
sense of the typical hard and fast date
this is when it's happened it's like hey
we're gonna tell you soon we're on the
cusp soon now again I don't know in
their defense
I'm not trying to rip them this could be
you know you know got the pandemic right
this could be the pandemic situation
being fluid you know they can't go into
the office and stuff like that you know
and instead of saying hey let's not
maybe maybe this is them saying to
themselves hey let's not promise them
that it's going to be that Tuesday that
we normally would say and give us some
rope give us some leeway just in case we
need a little more development time and
let's be real they've had a lot of bugs
they've had a lot of issues you know
what the quest thing that pushed back
maybe some things internally I could be
looking to more deeper to this but maybe
some things internally that they don't
want to tell us just yet is saying hey
we may not give us give ourselves
I'm giving my only counter to that yet I
literally say in 12 days we can't show
you what we were working on so I don't
feel like the season timing right is
going to change I get that but it's just
way too cryptic that unscripted
difference for me this is like an
unusual level of non-transparency
before a dlc
it could be me I could be looking into
this way deeper I don't know just wait
what we don't use the weekend we even
get the name usually they'll be like yo
everybody talk about it but all this one
is called season of opulence like oh
okay and then we knew we'd be theorizing
at least they'd give us the name or Dan
giving us nothing so it is um it's
interesting and the last point I will
say is this I got a question for you um
remember how they said that the way they
develop season and content is two at a
time right where is worthy enrollees
worthy number two in relationship to the
season of it's all in the works for a
while yeah okay so it's very V and then
this next season coming up to that we'll
work on together
or was it worthy and I never would say
like it's probably specific that they do
two at a time I would say the
prospecting I think they're working to
in advance like they could they're
probably work working on worthy like
being three months away they were
working on that during on potentially
six months out in it I think they always
had a potentially so they were covering
two months of content so they had that
skip it's not like these two are
developed in succession and then there's
a hard and fast line it's the next loca
it was my understanding it was like
while night like nine and ten are being
worked on and then as nine finished lake
there's that progression is like as nine
is out ten and eleven are being worked
on and as Ryan comes out eleven and
twelve are being worked on so it's like
right that progression is always like
they're working at the same time as that
runs so when what they learned from nine
they couldn't implement until say okay
six months down the road that was the
way I interpreted that okay I know I
think again I'm just trying to and this
could be I can either overanalyze
but is it would it just was very cryptic
to me and the last point I want to make
and I never got a chance to talk to you
about this and actually haven't even
talked about an Ohio podcast and I'm
dying to which is speaking they spoke to
Phil Spencer recently just about how the
pandemic effects development right you
know what blew my mind
that you can get most stuff done from
home right but if you're making a new
game or new content the hardest thing
they said is mocap yep and music
orchestra because all those things
require you to be a mocap requires the
docs and all and add to come in you know
I'm saying all it should require you
it's almost I don't say impossible but
you each individual thing has to be
synced and cut and you know I'm saying
then merged into it there's a lot of
components to it so I actually am
concerned for development in the future
I don't know how how far ahead they were
we before the the pandemic and how
prepared they were I don't know what
does maybe this affects d3 maybe this
doesn't affect you know I mean they'll
be but the later season of d2 you know
I'm saying like MIT like 2020 ones
version of destiny d2 no you know maybe
it affects that but I'm very curious
because we even saw a shout out to lemon
we Sean Lance Reddick in the closet with
the box set up like they're having to
get creative so what I want is somebody
see what I'm trying to say is this I'm
actually giving them benefit in doubt
you know we don't know how much
development has really affect them
because some studios in gaming are
prepared and so and we're prepared and
had the tools maybe things are already
in place and done and in other Studios
maybe scrambling and I'm hearing expect
a lot of delays now about turns a Bungie
I'm just talking about in terms of the
games industry Oh exact a lot expect
especially these new games it's in
development bro you need mocap you need
to come in you need you need you need on
August really and I'm saying a lot of
stuff can't be done so this is we're in
a very weird time and I think the vibe I
got from Justin was he was he didn't say
like it wasn't coming out you're right
he we said 12-day but he stressed video
game development being messy you know
God he said hey we're working from home
you know the laptop said he's telling us
as a studio the things they're having to
endure so we have to pay attention to
those little T
I feel but I'm done renting I just want
to know what your feeling is what did
you get out of it in general cryptic
word I was like it was on the tip of my
tongue for a while and then I finally I
was like put a finger on the word I was
like yeah that's the right way for me to
phrase it
I mean I said it earlier in the podcast
those like typical cadence is like yet
season of the undying three weeks before
the undying mind is here then we gotta
kill him for a while and do that type of
stuff
okay so we kill him enough of course you
know just they say hey you killed enough
billions of copies we've completely
killed it in on all timelines we did our
thing and that prompted the next season
but we we got the final activity and
then they like you know did the little
shoestring bowtie and barely put the
seasons together right go into season of
dawn okay so you have like your
cinematic on season of dawn we have
paint 14 come in we have Osiris and the
sundial doing his thing try and protect
the sundial then we get the heroic
because we have Ino Tom and he's like
this kind of cooler version we have that
stuff going on we have the end of the
season cinematic which I can't remember
when did that one with Osiris drop that
was like around this cadence it was
almost like a two week because it wasn't
like end of class or something it wasn't
last day it was like a two-week end of
seeker that's why we were like y'all we
figured we were gonna get something this
week with almighty and stuff cuz wait
because this is this week like how many
more weeks after it's cuz it's not never
have 12 days so we have a week Tuesdays
like a week yes so this week
I thought for sure we may get um some
day shout out to UM Ares he said he did
you get the Xbox article he sent you did
you get something Xbox right he sent you
yep I didn't I looked through it so he's
talking about what is a reference to
yeah talking about the 60 frames and how
they're like upscaling oh as far as the
advancements with Bungie yeah just the
way for backwards compatibility of just
like how it's just gonna be able to take
your games like but not all yeah that's
all that's of bility journey and
everything like that like yeah there are
so many things going on between of what
the SSDs can do and what the new
technology's gonna do and just like mmm
it's like and the quote here is like
we're able to create whole new classes
of innovations including the ability to
double the framerate of sort of a select
set of tiles from 30 to 60 or 60 to 120
literally if you're just like framerate
double I mean it's not as easy as
snapping my fingers obviously that's
stupid but the fact that they can take
games that typically run at said
framerate and this is the resolution
this is what they're built on now they
have the power
like we can do that exact same thing
just run it at 60 frames if they're able
to just find that switch in that power
to be like we go it seems with Xbox bro
like that article that Ares she's
talking about that was super impressed
they talk about any games without any
boost mode or whatever and you're
getting 60 to 120 frames that gave me
full confidence and good or in destiny
on console and you know in the fall when
it comes out but back to your point with
the with the whole with the 12 yeah nvme
storage is gonna be beautiful
though obviously it says keep your eyes
trained on bungee for updates prime
example live in the middle of the dam
podcasts so that's fun will stream our
announcements in our usual places you'll
learn about so for B before all this
stuff went down in the last like 24
hours mm-hmm
theory Tuesday was potentially gonna be
almighty and the reason I wanted the
almighty to be on Tuesday is because
what I had figured is Tuesday ii was
gonna be a teaser tuesday this wednesday
the third would be the trailer right
that's all about the redacted and i went
back with the stream and we went to
watch one of the old moon Vioxx
you're good went back and got one of the
mood Vedic sand literally listen to that
and they talked about the difference
between multiple seasons like season I
and things will start going season
tenants building in season 10 is gonna
be like something you've never that
we've never done before
so if season 11 is something they've
never done before we're at a point where
if they're gonna make something that big
and grand of a promise back in September
they had this planned so then I'm like
okay so if it's big and grand they want
to tell us about it so I was like if
this season 11 trailer was gonna be on
Tuesday Wednesday that timeframe and
Almighty somehow happens on the same day
as like the cool part of the almighty
cinematic is gonna get to live for like
an hour before turn around and like hey
here comes the teaser here's the trailer
and they all my T's forgotten and I'm
like that would just put the literal
nail in the coffin of the season that
has already been questionable in the
first place I was like so a wanted time
for the Almighty to breathe that's
obviously not happening because it's
parked out there for whatever reason so
okay so then I was like all right so
maybe next week everything does happen
all together we get the Almighty we get
the teaser we get the trailer maybe
that's what happens and then you read
you'll learn about the next season of
destiny too at the same time we talk
about the next chapter in the story that
has been unfolding all year long
so they talked about the next season and
the next story but it seems to be with
the pyramid ships on the light bright
wall and all that stuff that whatever is
gonna be happening they can't tell us
because it's gonna tie into the fall as
well it's my guess to say yeah that's
literally what I was about to say I
think that's what's going on here and I
think you know who said it but I think
Prescott's W Prescott said it earlier it
almost feels like the Almighty was
really just a distraction for what they
really want to do and to your point
there there isn't the proper time payoff
for Almighty to really get it just do
but it's gonna be the vibe we're getting
a damn BAM or body's done and then this
thing is hot yeah that's when he was
like it's gonna do it that's where it
seems and it's just again based on what
we're used to
it's a little different you know I'm
saying howdy Hannah now I will say this
if they hand
that you know pretty in a cool fashion
I'm not gonna say all is forgiven for
sees what cuz it's not but it would be a
nice lead up they got it they got to do
it right right and I think just that's
just been the worry this season with
with season and were they just things
have not executed right on on many
levels that I think that's been the
theme of season and worthy is execution
not lack of execution just not hitting
things and and getting the feel right
with this particular one so listen I'm
hoping you know I'm hoping they they
think they at least put a nice little
bow at the end of this is it's just been
a horrible season I mean it's just no
sugarcoating it is no this is just where
we are now I want to see the transition
you know does this thing blow up do we
get our debride do it you know yeah
that's what you guys into yeah and again
Tessie had a good article and it's again
it's what you can really hope for but I
don't expect it in a season level thing
yeah expectations now there is the lake
leaked footage out there of a damaged
tower like a place behind every verse
there's apparently like this like feel
like a piece that crashed so potentially
whatever happens with the almighty maybe
some of it does come crashing down and
like Clips the tower or something like
that
now what I would love to see not gonna
happen it's a season I understand it
unless it's like something they've never
done before when they blow my skirt up
but if I would love if somehow they
explode the almighty and then like the
new map for the European dead zone or
whatever has a chunk of the wing
almighty across the zone here and
there's like debris in the actual game
from this giant ship and then somebody I
think in my twitch at guess said
yesterday well didn't the Fallen just
trying to get on the almighty ship and
trying to steal technology and we're
fighting with them and then maybe likes
even stuff but like I would love to see
them actually start to change the world
because I honestly mainly in saying that
it's been three years of the same
European dead zone they need to mix some
of these areas up I you are muted by the
way oh yes let me know
yeah I'm with you I'm with you oh it's
YUM I mean shout-out to who's a DJ I
just think it's wishful thinking oh I'm
not saying it's not it's likely that the
scale of seasons it's a ten-dollar
season I'm not setting my expectations
that that hi I wish that stuff would
happen I don't expect it at all we just
feel you you got the right monster up
just I have so little faith that season
worthy like I am so done with this
season I it just needs to be
it's a nightmare that had needs to be
over bed I'm the same way it's like and
this it cannot get here soon enough
because it's killing me that we have to
like wait now my other theory of this
entire thing nothing happens on Tuesday
now this is now this takes like this
takes them doing it perfect and this is
again I don't even know how they could
orchestrate the timing of all this stuff
so this is dumb
crazy theory of ebon test right now so
your breakfast break is there we go
Tuesday nothing but the ship does get
bigger out there so they're showing like
progression of the almighty somehow on
the 9th this would be like the dream
setting by the way so not holding breath
go far if you're standing in the tower
oh here we go
you get to see the Sky box with like an
explosion of the almighty getting blown
away if you're in the tower on like June
9th that like I like 9 a.m. or something
enough time for them to shut down the
servers if that happens it explodes
lights kind of flare you get kicked out
of the game they close the server's down
and that's when they go live with their
twitch stream explaining next I know I
know I know and again this is like
beyond dream setting of earlier of them
like actually changing up the EDC
context so but yeah they they kick
everybody out cuz they got to do a patch
then they're like hey catch us live in
like 15 minutes we're gonna be live
talking about the next season on the
fall and all of that type of stuff now
that takes a hell of a timing execution
servers hit the switch go live on like
all that stuff happening at the same
time this is what season 2 were together
man doing right now Hey look how
creative he is like he's just covered up
he's cooking up I mean great ideas right
now so the main the main reason I'm
wondering is for one they say stuff they
say we'll talk about the next chapter
which could just be the story narrative
but also the season so they could be
talking about season 11 but as we talk
about season 11 they keep mentioning
year for they're like we even told you
how year 4 begins we're gonna do that
soon yeah now my question is does season
11 like spoil year for
does is season 11 I have enough in
because it's gonna connect potentially
yeah it does that spoil what's coming
and this is like the season 11 reveal is
also the year for like initial
information push like do you think those
could be that connected or is it season
9 they do the season thing or June 9th
to do whatever the season thing or maybe
the week before either way and then
maybe a week or two later once we've
seen the season
hey this is the fall expansion sometime
in June were given the fall expansion my
question is is it June 9th which is even
still a little late for them usually
versus like III would have been this
coming next week yeah cuz I mean flying
I was I was technically flying out to
eat three next week yeah so I mean so if
they were gonna do an e3 push it was
like first week of June right the season
launches in the second week of June
already so it's a little later than
before you get later in June and stuff
things start to more and more stuff like
it feels like you this coming week and
they state and in twelve and they only
date they give in twelve days we can't
wait to show you show you more of what
we've been working on it's like mm-hmm
if we don't see anything for 12 days I'm
going to lose my freakin happy so
actually I'm pretty sure I already have
by all the combination of them but I
think I'm putting it together now I
think I got it this is e three time
right so I think the issue here with the
cryptic mess I just I just got it it's
it's literally remember they have
already been revealed to be on Geoff
Keighley summer game events yeah some
yet they are part of that the only
reason they would and I believe they
they were they did that what shadow keep
so all of them as da de he's adorable
I know oh he's so creative but the thing
is like they always use that to be a
precursor that's there remember the most
eyes are on you you want to hype up that
next thing that's coming so I think
that's the stage where we're really
gonna get I think we may get a double
dose as far as this week that we come in
you know finish off in game Almighty
we finish that off finished to see if we
get into whatever this season is that
probably will be a precursor and then
September it I mean June what is it 12
or whatever that date is they're gonna
be there
we're gonna get a big chunk and I think
they're gonna do I'm putting together
now I think this is this about it's the
Carlito prediction 10-fold got my CB
Greiner turn yeah I got my CB realm all
right so what I'm what i think is
remember how shadow keep we got the
content drop but we got the big
announcement cross save remember that
was huge at the time that not blue turd
and we got free to play right it was
like a bull bull explosion shadow keep
here we go what I think we get is
something similar in a sense of you know
hype whatever the new name of the
expression is cinematic trailer of where
whatever we're not prepared for and then
boom next generation consoles guaranteed
you know 60 frames because mama next-gen
is coming all the new systems have to
start for the most part PlayStation 5
all these guys got to start revealing
now this June is the month but next-gen
consoles to get high so he's gonna do
their crap like next week I swear yeah
I'm here know I've heard a shout out to
Jason I think it's like what does it
third win third yeah it's it's also
that's net remember next week
Playstations gonna talk you know saying
the week after this is the make well
maybe I think they talking this is the
next gen Kate it's not neat I sighs
don't get gas I feel you on cross play I
don't I don't know you know I would love
for it to happen I don't know if we're
there yet I think here's the remember
Xbox just announced backward
compatibility everything boosting up
we're back in back I think for the most
part we're gonna get that sixty and
they're gonna talk about how much
destiny hat will improve on the consoles
and the things they're doing and that's
gonna be this whole mass media marketing
push and that's what we get back it's
like that during summer of games I still
think they're gonna do their twitch
stream because Bungie still does those
every
there's maybe some of their their own
stream but yeah then summer game fest
will be those type of like system-wide
announcement 60 frames for D for like d2
in the fall that type of stuff but they
will reveal it on their own games
because we crush those things so that
will come first but remember their new
hour-long Lincoln na mele Luke and
doctor country Luke in them you're right
they did do their twisting you're
absolutely right
remember Luke in them then went on Jeff
stage last year and was like yo destiny
is free to play destiny ask cross save
those are huge announcements on the e3
level so I think you're right twitch is
where they'll reveal the content right
yeah you may get up you know you may get
you ain't gonna travel all that stuff
but I think whatever system wise or
back-end wise for the next gen we're
gonna get on that Jeff Keaney state
they've got that relationship they've
got that I think they continue that you
know so we'll see we'll see this this is
gonna be I think we'll get a lot a nice
answer to a lot of this cryptic trout
stuff you know I'm saying cuz they can't
say anything yeah no go ahead say so
hmm wagers hahaha do you give me a date
or oh give me a date for almighty and
give me a date for next season trailer
not teaser trailer now when you say
almighty you mean or when does the
almighty get blown out of the sky
that's the first one I think that's
joules second okay that's Tuesday okay
right and then June 31st is not a day by
the way thanks sorry appreciate that
Vagabond oh no not you I'm giving about
no crap he did that on purpose did your
job 234 oh yeah I just see this message
okay I got I got it yeah yeah
so that okay so you're June 2nd Almighty
trailer date for season of the redacted
yeah I think trailer date for season of
the redacted
Manjula second they blow it up cuz June
9th has got to be the season like we
were mean the season ends in game the
season still shows like we have 11 days
left to play
right so that is tonight right so June
now okay that's the new season they've
got to do the trailer I'm gonna say
Thursday on that table there I'm gonna
say the fourth I'm gonna say June 4th
I'm looking at the calendar right now
because that would be perfect because
PlayStation announces they thing we're
gonna get a whole bunch of next
generation of gaming now oh yeah I'm
going with the 4th man I'm going with
the second is to blow up and the season
kind of abrupt with their mighty but we
get it done fourth we start getting what
the hell the new stuff is about and then
the knife would just go right on into
that bad boy that's what I'm wrong with
but I'm going to weigh you
dan dan I was like blown out of the sky
isn't taking up that things the size of
the planet
see that's why I would love to see that
thing crash into the European dead zone
I mean its massive Hatchin it's like
Armageddon blow up the asteroid now it's
just two smaller asteroids it's still
freakin huge
like no ayah sighs no more exclusive
state I don't think it's gonna happen I
think I will I will say this though this
is where I think you are onto something
somebody's gonna get the marketing deal
that's different that we got a pant and
I already got my money or who that going
help Phil Spencer and Pete pauses love
doing streams together now they love
being on camera together destiny was if
you have the X Cloud Service destiny is
free on exile service right now the Phil
Spencer that told y'all don't let that's
these it's prey for one of his favorite
games they're not gonna have exclusive
content but she's not in the business of
locking out eggs I that was Activision
stuff that day they're not taking those
deals anymore
but marketing is DIF that just says who
gets to show it on the stage right so to
speak and I could see it I could see I
could see you know if um you know maybe
they debut one of the new a new trailer
you know and listen we can't say shout
today no we can't act like bunch you
don't need that money you know saying we
can't act like any damn you see they
ever verse store these days better yeah
it's true that's true I could see I
could see a scenario you know but um
yeah that's about the good good question
I sighs III think it will be interesting
to see her I mean maybe I could be wrong
maybe they don't show up on anybody
stage and they just show up on their own
stage like they did last year as far as
their own twitch stream and then just
give you announcements but I would think
marketing deal you know makes sense for
them you know just alive people are
there to cross and I'm not trust me I'm
not just going to fill pincers Phil
Spencer and Pete Parsons relationship go
but I still think they are play anywhere
so if you go marketing campaign on any
specific platform mm-hmm I think I would
be surprised if they pushed it
that way 10 I'm not saying it's not
possible I'm just saying I don't think
they will we forgot we forgot something
that we were overlooking something from
last year that's hue lady huh yes they
had a stadium marketing deal that was a
marketing deal for like I said it wasn't
exclusive but they would you know so
again it is interesting it is
interesting how they will present that's
my I love podcasts love right there who
say the Book of X that's I'll be right
there
oh yeah man listen I won't be surprised
I would not be surprised a marketing
deal makes sense but you know they get
that they have to be up for it but they
did have one with stadia as far as
streaming you know there's gonna be the
next is gonna be fine now I'm excited I
went from being all down to like I am
super pumped now I've completely
forgotten it we are an e3 territory now
undeveloped sort of in the last week I
would have been with you yeah and then
I'm like damn he I ain't gonna be able
to do the last word next week cuz I'll
be out there in LA and then obviously to
pee dammit and then you know I'll be
getting them news I'd be on a show but
I've been doing a solo less word when
they drop the trailer been like dude
he's not here fun y'all strapped in
trapping I'm actually I went from
Madeline I'm super hyped right now now
like you have no idea you just excited
is it's on it's on now we hope it's all
I have to play counter one
just to see just hope for something cool
I'm for the world changing on the 9th
crazy day now I will say if it's on your
side
I think Prescott had it pretty
accurately if I'm wrong I think the
trailers on Wednesday because that gives
people to discuss for 24 hours and then
there's the tois and then they'll do the
season of the word and then they do the
season have the redacted like web page
will come up later that day and then the
12 still the discussion they break down
some other stuff there mmm get a
calendar all that stuff's like broken
that Wednesday Thursday yeah so if
that's the case
Tuesday it blows up when Tuesday teaser
for like 10 seconds
Wednesday trailer Thursday crazy 12
right podcast on Friday it should be
glorious Oh next week though of that if
that happens all like that mmm yeah
Friday will be like a three-hour podcast
oh yeah absolutely you're breaking a
barrier I don't know if we will should
get a calendar this season that's
actually a fair point do you do you want
a calendar um yeah I would like like we
would like a road map we enjoy those we
like when you do the nice little cute
pictures in the and the dates we like
that I mean but in their defense this is
a pandemic world now you know we I have
to be respectful of deadlines and things
of that nature but um I'm so curious but
I wish we had someone behind the scenes
in terms of development because I am
very curious how they do their
cinematics is that all
computer-generated like when Zavala and
Anna Bray you know what talk is that
some of that I mean you've seen you've
seen I feel it's more going done' to
mocap I've seen her do mocap you've
who's that that's on eros eros yep she's
done well you seen her do more category
I think she did mocap for shadow keep it
looked like she's like hmm
we're all insufferable or whatever and
it looks like she's looking around now
maybe that's just like for that for that
scene I think the in-game stuff like
this of all the pieces those are just
like CGI they render
they put his voice on the top like that
I picture as that way but I think furs
at least had something for that but I
don't know again I think they could do
it without just the mocap gives it a
little more natural animation to it
because like her performance is like
she's sad to Dan we need Marco yeah
chorus she's going back in the bushes
there's nothing going on but my warlock
she she needs you she needs to I agree
um yeah I guess you're right I mean
probably maybe a mix um you know I feel
like the season picture Lance Reddick
doing mocap they've never show as much
as I see his him being his social media
presence right and then I feel like we
would have seen him potentially like and
he doesn't ever have any like crazy
scenes or anything he's usually walk
around talk like the character itself
isn't doing anything crazy we looking
for a visit
I agree so and we've confirmed that he's
doing new voice-over work for destiny
we've already confirmed so clearly arm
yeah it might be it might be it might be
what you call it in my but here's the
thing I think mocap might be reserved
for the big expansion content Prescott's
and same old shot the present always say
the same thing okay yeah so it's like I
think dad's reserved for that whereas
the season stuff is probably small you
can get away with cinematic stuff yeah
it's gonna be interesting man it's gonna
be interested um
I'm high next weeks buckle up man
Michael loved it I transform that my
whole negative energy there like it's
like this whole weekend is just like me
just like tapping my fingers on the desk
just like the hated this whole season to
get done cuz right now I'm just like
chips not gonna change there's gonna
show up by the way sir does have random
roles starting next season right and oh
yeah
boom ninth not this week or next yeah
I anticipate next season being like a
warm mind kind of a season which was a
prelude to for sega where a lot of
smaller systems get introduced and
gameplay changes that are beneficial
before we get those massive ones in
Forsaken / season of the what else we
got like exotic catalysts and warmer I
like member way up that's a lot of cool
things dad saying it's gonna be scoring
for next season I want to get your take
I don't see it I don't know how that
ties in I could see Siva I can see
fallin I'm just not seeing or scoring
would be what yeah let's guess what do
you what do you who do you think would
be dude I don't freaking know like
luckily if the rasputin's tie is
anything at all because they aren't have
tried to have some connection from one
to the next
mm-hmm even if it's like a shoe strings
worth of a tie there's some little
inkling between the two no if that is
the case like Osiris goes to talk to
rasputin's obvious then press Putin's
been like the thing for the season we've
been working with ok Rasputin's
had the little like fell winter siva
teased background Sivas locked in right
round i could see it being siva related
okay so and on it and this so there's
been some funny things that like fly
through my twitch chat at some points
when I'm playing and somebody was like
what if you know it's a shot at the
almighty that does it miss or maybe the
almighty crashes or something like that
happens because instead of firing at the
almighty Rasputin fires at the pyramid
ships to like slow them down it's like
that'd be cool I don't see it but I'd
love to see something kind of like that
or is it the fact that Siva is something
if we can harness it for the good and
obviously not let it go bad but because
I mean there's been too many you've got
the transmat effect you've got the
ornament for both a weapon yes and with
the chest like has been plastered all
over it like everywhere it's in a lot Oh
maybe Sivas away that Rasputin's like
blame you know that bunker that killed
my
son go back down there let's see if we
can get this thing harnessed up because
those pyramid ships aren't slowing down
next season they're gonna be a lake at
Earth come the fall so Siva might be our
way to fight them I agree I think I
think it will be used for a Guardians to
weaponize against because like you said
it's been hinted all over ever verse I
mean Lord of wolves now has a Siva
version you know I'm saying there's a
lot of a lot of siva fide stuff so yeah
they are definitely it does feel like it
will have a role you know coming up soon
to quit the question comes down to arm
you know whether it's going to be deer
season coming or you know the big season
of the you're not ready that's the
question as to when you know we're gonna
get back i do a graphics eva is
definitely gonna be a factor I mean the
other one in Crystal saying it as well
is we went Osiris Don right or mind
worthy what was after war mines forsaken
right but then the question is okay do
you have the Dreaming city tie-in or do
you have the aldryn tie-in and is Marisa
out there now that was another thing
we'd like to talk to myself into this
little change and I was like so maybe
somehow we get like an Aldrin tie-in
maybe we get a hunter Vanguard situation
and then if all drones actually back
before the pyramid ships get here the
Queen might be on our side to face the
pyramid ships like again I'm full of it
but it's like no not which that cadence
still also make sense so is the like
dream and so when we get to forsaken
Aldrin is the biggest yeah keep thinking
about him and that's why I'm very clear
like I don't hold on put a pin in that
so that won't like the cinematic of the
Almighty explodes and then Aldrin takes
off his helmet in the tower exam and
Zavala and I Cora see him and that's
where it cuts and you're like hey fire
let's know you know say I mean here's
the date and where they gotta be careful
the only excuse I give them for
introducing anything new is if it's
darkness related right
we have gotten to a point where there
are too many in
productions and nothing is finished or
completed too many you know like Oh does
not finish what you call it callus is
not finished there's so many unfinished
bits it is just like they just like to
say you know show something new squirrel
and then we forget about stuff there
yeah like bro like we got all these
loose and shout out the mellow yeah we
got too many loose ends oh like ultra
needs to happen you know I'm saying now
sorry cher that's a his in chat he's
like can I shoot all during again and
I'm sitting there thinking like he's a
guardian you can shoot him again and
again and again and it's like he he is
the new firing range for Fallout when
he's shooting weapons Aldrin is just
they're constantly being shot and that's
what makes Lara come back and be like
dude stop killing my brother what the
hell Phillips our killer
yeah they got we got to get some beats
done man we the oldrin thing I mean
remember how hot I guessed incorrectly
you know I thought he was gonna be part
of this season of the world like how
better is season two worthy would have
been as like he would have been fitting
in there and so Siva Aldrin I could see
both of those in some ties if it's older
and they could use the Dreaming city as
its high-end to kind of see if that's a
thing mhm I mean you're dreaming city is
kind of up on the cadence it's it's
dreaming city you know none of that
stuff in a while so it's like what is
that it would be almost two years
basically yeah once that was like a main
focus right right and then we still got
the curse pit it's that's another part
that's still curse oh the three-week
cursed yeah dude I want that fixed I
feel sorry for the awoken they're just
like this sucks
they're just tortured and blues just
sucks three weeks here we go what's the
Grand Theft Auto nearing marching in
like every day waking up back to it hold
on back to the grind like mmm man I mean
it's so many is so many beats that we we
gotta get done it but yet a cadence is
definitely time you know um babe maybe
that is next season maybe maybe they
push that up and then
you know we obviously heard the rumors
of Europa when it comes to darkness and
stuff you know yeah I mean new possible
destination your hope is been thought
about for a while also potentially you
know Davey leaks possible if there's any
gear midships where we fight them I mean
those are those are big rumored possible
question marks and stuff like that and
then yeah I'm I want to know I don't
have a deal oh we're talking ourselves
in circles we could be dreaming city or
we could be Siva mmm I can't quite
imagine what Siva would do to the
dreaming city those two are Lakes so far
sorry separate angular technical and
like like just I want to say the curves
which sounds wrong but like the the like
beautiful ornate nature of or not me
yeah architecture of the of the dreams
of city yeah let me ask y'all what would
y'all want what Chad I need it like
would y'all want a Siva story assuming
the darkness is not the next season
would you guys wanna see the story or
would you guys want a dreaming city
style story you know I'm saying like
okay I'll just go so crystal says Siva
hold on I'm gonna hole up there I can do
it put a pole but to pull up but Apolo
I'm very curious what people want
because obviously if then it's evil a
ton you know I'm saying
diva related more dreamin three-minute
vote get in there get to voting it's up
ya know click above the twitch chat and
you guys can vote mm-hm
cuz I can see both being viable and both
actually have feeding ways that can
attend I could see Aldrin bringing Mara
back as a way to fight the pyramid chips
I could see Siva as a way for Rasputin's
help us fight the pyramid like you know
two different paths to fight the
darkness and again both potentially
viable because if it's this this crazy
strong nanotechnology or mera saath
who's
like small planet killing powerful crazy
woman and so she's if we do Sivir I have
a request
my man Saladin needs answers
he would be a perfect person to say he
would be perfect and also pissed pissed
dude where's um where's lady what is her
name who didn't I effort effort he wears
demon by the way she is she dead or she
just out there late yeah I would love to
see an iron lord story come back again
bro I know I know I know lots but like
to like have that happen and like this
is like Siva story and then we get the
word Saladin is that true I'm sorry to
cut you is that true they say that all
mela says a crystal is saying that um
she's a effort it's a pacifist maybe I
missed that law yeah she's kind of I
think she ran off to kind of avoid all
the fighting at this point maybe sounds
gonna right okay well in the red war
okay yeah okay she just went away
remember when she was like host and iron
banner for a bit remember that yeah you
know Saladin needs we can do a little
rise of ivory redo oh man Saladin
definitely cool so obviously we're
pretty split we're 43 percent for Seva
50:17 senator dreaming cities hoto but I
mean that's both could work its kind of
what we're getting to
so yes yes I agree it's interesting I
mean oh yeah give me that old school or
Dharma yes our pauldrons and my chest I
want hot fire
I don't allow me okay here's the only
problem that's gonna be a reissue for
the fifth time no I like that one but we
want that one come on again what that
one we want that one I know we want it
what lissa van so this next week yeah
come next Friday's podcast which would
be the fifth days are correct
June 5th podcast
we're gonna hopefully have some stuff to
talk about or we are going to be pulling
our hair out waiting for stuff to talk
about
if I'm right I am honestly going to be
happily surprised I just don't see them
pulling that off as they're already
tweeting something now that honestly
leads me away from that because if
they're tweeting now that's like tweet
over the weekend kind of everyday Monday
Tuesday stuff happens like if they start
teasing us now and it's like 12 days
away people are going to go insane me
first by the way let me say this and I
know we got to talk briefly I'll talk
briefly about out writers in a bit but
um you know that's the thing destiny
does well like when it comes down to
marketing the next content man you know
saying it so I buckle up man buckle up
there's stuff cooking that does the
cryptic nature of what's going on cannot
wait to see which direction they take it
because man we need some juice into this
case she has said badly and I think
they're gonna also like I said teasers
for that future content and man you know
say he said you know who got what that
film back so miss Phil Dominus we'll see
we'll see you guys receive it Phil got
cooking hopefully you know I'm saying
well hopefully it's a marketing deal but
um yeah man like I think Lauren we're
gonna be in a good little spot these
this next month and and I think we will
forget about though the season that was
not worth we will get about this dark
time and it was funny somebody was
saying the Almighty
we literally have we're gonna have the
almighty in our thoughts for like the
first day and maybe like when it blows
up and that's the title of the entire
season mm-hmm and it's like you could
have had so many other things like
Seraph or so many other titles that felt
like they would have been more fitting
da mafia and almighty is also a bit
gratuitous as well over that's just like
over-the-top and be like I'm a pompous
almighty I am late the weird title to me
like I think that one's kind of oddly
chosen yeah I went it was yeah it's kind
of kind of weird
and maybe because they try wanted to try
I mean well it's this is supposed to be
the trial season let's just be real
yeah before on this title for that true
true true true like the autumn ideas
like yeah again if the almighty is the
title I have a Santa a skybox update in
a two minute cinematic to open the
season everything else has been
Rasputin's son serif towers bunkers
nothing related to almighty as entire
time so I feel that more I feel a part I
feel that part doesn't mean somebody
said it knows like yeah I don't know if
I could wait almighty is just like mmhmm
yeah yeah and also it's related to this
season and also like the way you had to
do that last triumph it's just like you
pissed you off a little more because you
like the nine people by public event
worlds please don't do that again please
stop with the public events let's not do
it related stuff mmm let no more
community driven narrative based events
I don't quite a community stuff
I don't want community public event
counters yeah like that like quarters of
time was cool to a point and that was a
different way the community it was like
they have to keep coming up with weird
stuff but like the public event and then
the public events those yeah just
salting and open wound that that one man
I can't wait did you switching gears oh
Allah did you see that outriders stream
sir yeah so out Raiders everybody's like
oh the next s-stop saying that by the
way I know yes that inhaler oh my god
destiny has been around for a long time
people will hope to be as successful
because nothing else you have to go for
adoption right now I am I intrigued by
it
yes what firm you from there stream
which was mmm I went to go like click on
the twitch stream and it was like live
in 25 minutes I was like scroll ahead
like those long live counters to appoint
him like you already told us the time
and then I was like oh yeah I missed it
let's see and then I had to skip 25
minutes of like the pre video I'm like
all right so can we not do that yeah two
minutes then go like that's all you need
a couple minutes and go like people will
still be there they'll be waiting people
will talk in chat before you alive if
you tell them when to be there yeah what
you think though just overall
impressions of the reveal solid I
thought it was solid um I had seen it
before um they had an issue review I
want to shot some um yeah Doug and Doug
him from IGN he was up there and he
would kind of fight like doing like a
boss fight or whatever whatever and so
I'm getting like a mix mash of different
things
I definitely I'm definitely getting um
the third-person Division II over the
shoulder you know running around you got
cover you know shower let's just get the
blatant stuff out the way
whoever this this trickster class is
straight up aesthetically looks just
like a hunter you know say so we got the
three we got the three Giants you know
saying one looks just like it even
though he's doing different things he's
doing time and space thing it looks
pretty cool oh look overall it looks
solid you know I think it's definitely
PvE based I don't personally look at
this as competition to destiny they seem
to be going away like hey we're not
games as a service yeah it's like a
mortar that's gonna start in the fence
yeah like yeah this is a cut and dry
like hey you know we're not an MMO we're
not doing microtransactions you know I'm
saying so the vibe I get they're
definitely in their own lane with that I
like the skill trees I like the
customization of the UI I thought that
was really cool that's nice to see I
think more yeah everyone takes something
absolutely these skill trees can remind
me of a very expansive d1 and then
you've got impasse two types of game
styles you know I'm saying cool I'm not
I'm not I don't know how I feel about
there running around I feel like there's
a lot of running around you know I'm
saying I don't know how I feel about
that just yet
um gum place you know I got a C it's a
variability based um put it this way I
think from what I've seen and how
they're doing Lou in the world tier
system they've got a chance to be around
you know the key for me is gonna be
in-game content what keeps coming back
once you beat said finite game yeah um
and you know an intrigue you know are
people going to be really drawn to this
is it is it going to you know listen
anthem came out strong we were remember
that right and I thought anthem still
look better than this that's just me you
nothing like anthem it when I saw anthem
for the first time I was way high I was
like yo you never saying you remember
you know shout to meet you stone who is
there for Tarsus we jumped off the joint
we was like oh this is this is something
this is it now I don't know if it has
that initial feeling it's I don't know
if it's the world it's something about
nothing's just screaming to be like you
know it this is kind of another
dystopian alien planet yeah yeah like
yeah like and dystopian probably the
wrong word cuz that's overused but it's
like around Duff's going wrong right
back fight somebody fight some humans
fight some monsters you got skills you
got abilities and in a sense that's not
a bad thing right thing right um I like
when they show the trickster you've got
like the time abilities the way legis
he's got to get in the mix and actually
do damage to get kills and heal himself
like those are gonna be different
the swipe to slow him down and the
trickle of damage afterwards yeah that
was cool I will say this is going to
start looking like closer towards a next
gen not quite it's not like Unreal
Engine 5 crazy reveal yeah but I will
say the lake it looked smooth from what
I could tell
pretty smooth there were a couple
hiccups but I mean stuffs gonna happen
their audio started to glitch later on
their video like in the end I was like I
need to download the video so it's
smooth so like whatever stream didn't go
quite so hot but they're running around
like I just got done running around for
like 50 hours in neo so I'm like if
there is some running and dodging you
like that I don't mind that more for the
sake of that mean combat is gonna feel
more active nuts yeah I can kind of like
jump in a destiny game and kind of move
around but we're like hey let me flip
over to this platform as it goes away
and shoot these enemies and then kind of
like move back it's not like I am active
in a boss fight like running right I'll
I do enjoy that type of feel it gives
cause I mean division to me especially
is like when you get into it it's so
tactical you are plastered to that card
or yeah you're stuck like you hover is
some life in Division two even more than
Division one like you have to be in
cover like pinky and like even when I
played gears like I hadn't played him
before so a point of reference but it's
like I don't want to feel like I am so
stuck cover I want to feel I want to
feel mobile and I liked the way that
looked so that was cool the skill tree
depth were like kind of the first half
as you said has some connections if you
want to pick but then you can deep dive
down a tree I want skill trees like have
you seen by the way the diamond shaped
skill tree for dusty that's been
floating around Twitter yes yes I would
love to see them do a little more of
something like that in the fall I don't
expect it but again right needs some new
stuff overall I think from what I've
seen I'm intrigued do I think it's gonna
be this awesome thing I don't know
Borderlands like that's like a stylized
crazy humor and guns that are just
bunkers I think this one has a little
more balance of a little more down to
earth because Borderlands is just but
crazy yeah it's a little more but also
you still have like a desti weapon loot
system I mean that's straight up a menu
they had a weapon that was quote called
sunsetting which God knows if that was
like photoshopped in there but
somebody's definitely poking some fun
right now there still wants that link
for that a destiny thing oh I'll have to
look for it I'll have to look for that
one honestly I don't
I've just seen it passed through my feet
I'll continue that because you talked
about the destiny kill outright it's
continued but I mean you've got multiple
abilities there's eight different
abilities that kind of like that where
you actually have more choices they've
actually got eight abilities you can
pick through ch3 you want to have active
it's got potential
and it looks like hey by yourself or
co-op it's got a decently long story
it's square you know they've got money
to build a pretty sizable game they've
been they've been doing some quality
stuff between Final Fantasies every make
a fantasy about yeah I just worry about
but what they house their own line how's
that game don't they got a whole line
game going on 15 for teens online for
teens alright how's that to me I don't
know I haven't really followed them but
I'm just what teen is like people love
14 okay
like it came out first they shut it down
and then since they brought it back
people absolutely love that game people
who started are like dude I'm like a
hundred hours in and now I'm getting to
that like most recent expansion and I
can't wait like they do that level I've
only heard awesome stuff about 42 so
it's them and people can fly so listen
it's got potato say this as much as it's
not wowing me
Chow to Deb it was a but um everything
make me deaf but that all salute as up
so um as much as it it's not wowing me
graphically or story just yet I do think
the gameplay seems strong enough that
it's going to be around right so the key
comes down to you know obviously not
them crashing and burning and I'm saying
like how anthem did initially you know
it was like yeah it feels like they've
got a better foundation foundation right
yes but of course if you like you play
through it once and you're like that was
fine is the is like new because I mean
when I sit there and I play through neo
and I'm like I see the notion of what
New Game+ can offer I'm like dude I'm
honestly debating about playing that
more in these next couple of weeks to
experience that like will this have that
level cuz they said there's 15 world
tears but ain't I here world tier and
I'm like here we go again here we go
again
that anthem
Division two we've had these things of
like world tears and they only had like
three or five and this is 15 and I'm
like now they didn't say it was like you
could change it on the fly
mm-hmm yes so it was kind of organic
right yeah that would like how good you
are if you are dying or if you had done
yeah you had to stay alive long enough
to like unlock the next one yes just
like pick it
so you actually got to kind of
apparently get good mmm though it's got
potential
I mean to be one of those for me that
like but let's ask the magic question
huh that's asked of magic question cuz
I'm sure I got a shot my boy rage virus
Lords a game in that net what am i right
is the sister editor for was the
Internet
um he had a very interesting tweet and
we've gone back and forth I had to
attack him for this but his tweet was he
can see lots of destiny players leaving
destiny for this game and we got to talk
about it you know saying we got to me
not only as the game has an end it won't
hold them as long they might leave for a
season and then come back type thing
it's not Borderlands was the same
argument how long did that stay around I
tried to tell people but they don't
listen but my not that long no not that
like his comment was he can see based on
you know like this is the game he wanted
and he could see other destiny players
really and let's be honest in his
defense right he would do I don't agree
but in his defense destiny is out of low
low low low part right right now this
exact mo and this season prior right so
could this give destiny players that
have not you know could outriders be
that game like we had division we had
anthem you know destiny has survived a
lot you know I'm saying so um could it
be man could this be is finally the one
that could this be the Gok course that
slays the mightiest
yeah I was like and then yes like is it
no I don't think so
mostly because and then iron sights just
tagged us on the tweet if you want to
look at it as well I'll look at it no
it's just showing the inventories
straight up exactly what you would
expect resources I mean it's a destiny
inventory they've done it well for a
reason if you're not being what's the
flattery is the sincerest form of or
whatever oh yeah absolutely yeah so
I don't think any game that is not live
service is going to be the destiny
killer okay
personally and I'm not saying Destiny's
perfect it's not obviously we have low
points like this right now where they've
dubbed every toe on their foot
throughout the entire season it's been
kind of rough indeed private lunch the
almighty stories like may have the
shortest lived thing ever nobody likes
the public events the bunkers the lost
sectors like all we got is like a bunker
clearing thing that you can honestly
skip after you're done didn't do that
after a while and then you had public
events of which we did too many we were
so freaking tired of them mmm and then
trials just loved everywhere they're
like yes most things with this season
have gone poorly yet when you picture a
fall expansion then you're gonna try and
pull people away from the fall expansion
time when things are new and hot that's
when when it's at its best and if I
don't know when outriders comes out
that's what I gotta find out we got to
find out when it drops I'm very curious
the winds out riders release looking
that yeah they may not have even gotten
to that part yet but I will cities what
do you feel about I mean lets me really
look like it seems like it's going to
debut on next generation always so they
should have the graphical advantage of
using a lot of next-generation
techniques and I mean let's be real
bungees an old you know a current gen
game that's probably God I want is
that's why i wanted e3 is the new engine
here we go he says people can fly will
launch out riders on play it says
holiday season yeah so I mean essential
for next-gen for sure and that's when
they were running around when they were
blowing stuff up like I said it was like
it was kind of a gory game like the
stuff they were doing the slices they
had the x-rays skeleton showing like the
effects were legit like it looked good
and if that stuff's wrong and fluid if
you can run it for k 6d or 1440 60 or
however they pick their frame rates
anymore yeah who knows oona Dakota yeah
how are you awake right now
hahaha there's no agent should be awake
right now anyway mmm it has potential to
look good but as it has a start and a
finish if it's something some people
will latch on to that and they might do
like hey the Diablo Paragon levels this
is my new
some may do that but I think most Bailey
hey it's a cool experience I might try a
little bit of this next to your level
mm-hmm
but unless it's like ultra compelling
and there's like continual stuff people
work try it and come back that's what I
would say is like no I said in chat
they'll try it all even probably go try
it it looks how much I I'll try it I
think what they have going for them um
this is what I will say is what anthem
had over the division one of the few
things besides you know always look cool
was that bass man cause they hear exact
space magic right and not fighting you
know regular human dudes who don't have
any abilities you shooting ahead and
they got that you know saying cuz I know
that's your disconnect with division
right you know because you're fighting
creatures and now here's the thing like
I said shut up to Doug I actually
preferred his um IGN's showcase of the
game then I mean we got a lot of more
information in this one from square but
I like he actually did a boss fight I
don't know if you seen that one he's
fighting like some lightning dude
and that whew it felt cool you know say
it felt like okay even in this one there
was like the mini-boss that was like a
three times the size weird funky lizard
yeah
Lagos bigger things and that's where I
said like the movement is like hey if
they're like circling the boss and
getting around the back and doing those
types of things like mmm destiny is
fluid movement but it's not the fastest
movement right if that makes sense
yeah because you need a sparrow but if
lucky to have the fluidity of lake kind
of a super-powered ish being yeah and
also still have like the RPG elements to
it as well that's where again you
intrigue me so right like it seems like
potentially it's gonna be a lot of fun
is it gonna be the game that I'm gonna
be playing for the next three years no I
don't see that because it has an end and
something like that that has an end is
not gonna keep my attention and forever
especially because my backlog is forever
and I cover a game that just continually
lives so that's where it's hard no I I
hate you and I I'm being you on the same
page I will say this though if they're
able to get an add an endgame
if they write because let's be real one
of the major problems that division
really went division started off strong
division - hmm all the features all
doing the right thing saying the right
things doing the right things having it
said that was 30 and then what Dan we
didn't know they did say your endgame
ray I was like oh you learn it right and
then that ray dropped now in theory it
was like and that's where it's like a
raid based in reality right they did the
best honestly like the while it was too
damn hard burden Benny yeah they didn't
want it to be easy and walked over so be
like oh well division rates are too easy
so we're gonna make it break it
impossible
um eighth person raid like too many
people collected together it's already
hard enough to get people have learned
from world that's why world is no longer
40 person instances either they don't do
that anymore
but yeah I was like you're stuck in
reality and that was why anthem if
anthem had an end game but see I gotta
stop it for a second you completely
right and I'ma give it back to you with
the anthem thing but what division
messed up they had to put like you could
have fought like a helicopter so you
know that they you you couldn't done
supporting - actually yeah like they
just botched it like because to me that
they had the tools to be competitive
with destiny they had it and then they
just made this bonehead non-interesting
raid and but going into it the airport
was cool but what you thought was some
wack satellite I know a little thing
opens up why like so did lore and now
back to Europe I know you can go to aunt
the anthem man anthem could um I'm still
pulling for anthem man that was the one
I wanted to ever see the jet that's the
one I wanted to try to really do this
thing right man cuz they they had the
characters and the interceptor for me
was a blast
yeah the way that played on PC for me
fluid fast jump in fly being around all
over the place and then on the other
side and this is where it's like one of
the reasons I would love anthem to have
been more successful mm-hmm you can bear
an interceptor to a storm and they
cannot fall more silver and different
and unfortunately anthem we have a
different jump but we never feel that
different yeah you you miss the class is
really dope classes in ant like ant the
big Colossus the Colossus yeah a big boy
company tank in um saying I like this we
had a physical shield like he didn't
have like a projection shield he had a
physical shield like and I'm gonna
literally run through you with this
thing like room they had classes that
felt different and then you had your
jack-of-all-trades is like okay you pick
your Mario class versus your Yoshi's or
your bathroom just like you got sure but
it was like they had that but was like
there was nothing to do in that game
which was sad but they they felt
different and that's one of those things
if these classes we got to see the
trickster in this one if the others have
a different feel like this one's like
teleport behind him get your assassin
type swipes and you're covering time and
you're doing mm-hmm trying to forget the
other ones I know there was like the
time-space thing made a couple different
trees right if they make the classes and
one of them still a question mark class
they've only even mentioned three class
yeah yeah question about class at a
fourth so it's like if you have three
classes that have a distinct feel to
them that also gives people more reason
to at least even play it again yeah
Pyromancer trickster Devastator and an
unannounced fourth class they said
people can fire fire answer would be
like your mage then you have your
assassin Devastator will be like your
warrior you're more for class so that
makes us yeah look they got it they got
it they got a shot gameplay wise I think
they got they got a shot gameplay wise
boy it looks it looks snappy fluid fun
yeah space magic fun like you've got a
mix of a lot of varieties and guns and
you'll probably have some melee the big
melee so I like yeah they have they have
potential my my interest has been
triggered yeah like I said all I tell
people is just let's let's pump the
brakes on destiny killers oh yeah hey
that's what's done a new game comes out
and the first thing people say it's like
I don't know if you just hate that's me
that much that you have to hope and wish
this game to be dead that the next thing
cuz I heard it with anthem heart
division to it it's like let this game
breathe let it do what it's going to do
well every two comments can confirm some
people just hate this damn game yeah and
I get it I get it bro you know solitude
is if dad cop you know Aereo hyeri's it
even touch anthem it's just it just
kills me with the rhetoric and I'm just
like listen let these let these dudes
live they're in their lame they clearly
say that they're not trying to really be
in that games as a service beat they do
anything that has a lot of potential
let's see you know I'm saying but um you
know we've seen these games you know and
and enough another diver if I want to
please put to bed and we start with that
not you II but for people can we stop
with the destiny has it had any
competition no they've all been defeated
that's what it is all of them really
every time someone opens their mouth and
listen
Desi's at its lowest point right now and
still driving mad hard and you know what
happens but what's next week happens and
that trailer dropped in its season of
the oh my god it's on like Donkey Kong
you know exactly you know what happened
ocv greater build what's going on
brother in a go you know say so it's
like you know what I saw again I just
want people to just just pump the brakes
a new game I understand the new the new
girls here everyone wants to talk to her
okay I get it it's a new MMO whatever I
put hey this might be where I wanted I
get it let's just pump the brakes let's
let it let it live let it develop let's
see where they go you know I'm saying
and they gotta launch they gotta get
through and we'll see you know Sam but
at the end of the day that's T is going
to be destiny you know even in its
lowest point this is a cyclical thing we
know how this goes the rough spot and
then Irv is like we look back wrong just
the
spring seasons is like look but man
those fall expansions bro when it comes
up here and your time line is just
inundated with all the destiny when I
see every content creator talking you
know sir and the videos are popping and
the trailer is going and the new stuff
and sandbox and new weapons is some
destiny is something completely
different I this is where I give Bungie
so much credit when it comes to pure
gunplay all right you're gon play pure
marketing Pierce when when they actually
connect story beast they do it there is
nothing better than best being there but
that's where it just wins hands down you
know what I'm saying
so again I'm excited let's see what out
were out writers couldn't do you know
I'm saying let's see I'm excited but
well you've got like no writers you've
got God real going you've got you've got
you've got things that are gonna be fun
games and it's just life but it's like
mmm I will say in the world of gunplay
if you guys haven't tried it remnant
from the ashes yeah one of the better
feeling gun play games like Destiny's
first arson but for a third-person the
way that game played the way it like
felt some of the there is one of the
coolest reload animations on a gun I
have ever seen in that game Rana from
the ashes is awesome and it gives
scratches that Solich so it's like gun
Souls and I was like this is friggin
perfect like mm-hmm
the a but again I played through it
finish the story finish the story
experience played a little bit more came
back to destiny like exact games like
neo to freakin amazing inside for hours
like you'll have these adventures but
destiny is always gonna be pulling us
back yeah absolutely and the last thing
to is also when we talk about those
exotics and those guns it is exactly or
the dab the dab that's what's of it yeah
but like it is just something to be said
when you when you get these unique guns
and it is just nothing that feels stop
the deal melody said it's always gonna
be pissed something against it's a top
spot well I appreciate you saying it's
the top slot brother come
for you I know you like division as well
so I got it I got it I got a respect
that you know I'm saying but you know I
listen everybody wants that that destiny
bag so to speak you know sayin a the
other developers they see the success
they want to be part of finishes
remember when they announce finishes
Dakota listen now I will tell I will
tell everybody on this podcast to have
here's a little bit of homework
mm-hm if you guys can go back and find
two videos the one from June the out of
the shadows Vidocq and then the one from
September the moon and beyond go watch
those some things have aged well mm-hmm
finishers were cool some things like a
renewed focus on PvP that pack has not
aged well so there's things like you see
them really excite like the artifact
yeah and there's certain Blake when it
comes to the fall expansion this
excellent might be a fun thing if if we
don't have much to talk about next week
I kind of want to go rehash some of
these things so like relook back at the
previous year and see what literally
could get revealed next week we could
have god knows three hours to talk about
but not like the artifact that is
something I want to see evolve it has
been pretty se me for the past year yeah
though like the artifact needs to evolve
like the mods that somebody I forget
what I was listening to the mods from
the artifact not one of those have made
it into the game they said hey if we
like some from the artifact they may
come in writer that has come in um so
yes some of that stuff in those trailers
is cool and also go listen to the way
they described Season eleven Ares and I
like we looked for it lat the other
night and we listened it's like season
eight this season nine is the start
season 10 is kind of getting things
rolling season 11 is gonna bring
everything together that we built over
the past year and it's like mm-hmm god I
see it that's out to UM yes see me he's
like season will be like unlike any see
they're definitely going to do something
that is gonna be cataclysmic I feel in
the I also feel in the lore in
conjunction with gameplay one thing
about Bungie you have
omit when it comes to an expansion Conte
in September right though September
updates always bring it always the track
record speaks for itself
you know same question between shadow
keep rise of iron taken King forsaken
whatever September they not only
intraday introduce usually new gameplay
mechanics new things that it's just not
just your average it's almost like a
revamp I mean I'm saying in those day
and that's and we're at a point where it
potentially could have been a d3 and
that stuff's coming into d2 so I agree I
think it relies of iron t 2.0 in a sense
yeah in a sense
cuz I think they're not ready obviously
for d3 so we're gonna give you this this
big chunk of actually better it better
be bigger than rise of iron this has got
to be a taking king size forsaken II
this has to be taken for a second sighs
this can't be shadow keep reservoir if
it's that small that will be a struggle
especially if the pyramid ships are
involved it has to be one of the biggest
things yet because it's been building
for six years to me to show justice
Sharda did he say he plays the
expressions don't really care for the
sea listen a lot of people have been on
that bag shout out to get Dalian he's
been in that bag he's been like look
seasoned content is not for me and but
he said expansion content is for him hey
look that that's fine like that is
completely Bungie is okay with that
trust me when I say they are definitely
okay oh that's the game post it and pf5
announced what hold on Miss Aries Aries
just said there's something going on
another we got another destiny the game
announced a bit live we get a lot of
live stuff today man I know this is a
hell of a morning uh the future of
gaming so they have the picture I just
literally looked up PlayStation kataka
article had at first but there's a
picture of PlayStation 5 the future of
gaming join us June 4th
1 p.m. Pacific the 3 p.m. central 4 p.m.
for you on Thursday June 4th yeah oh so
you think in arm DM ok PS 5 that's the
game posted India announced you'll fall
but Ares is destiny I got it I got the
PS 5 reveal I got that that's that's
that's Hornet are you talking about the
weird sound graphic early
yeah I just want to make sure that he's
talking about the way or did he hear
something in conjunction with destiny
and PlayStation that's why I just want
to make sure because that would be even
that would be cataclysmic and I'm saying
shout out to Disney Lords again with
that net already on it mom man you gotta
see I got the tweets out I would put the
tweet out Louis a game with dad dad bye
guys out here working hard reveal yeah
they're big that's big yo that's big um
he said maybe we see with the power
cable I let me go get the hopefully we
get the console man hopefully get to
console you've seen the controller we've
got it yeah next I'm telling you man
number what I've told you eat you got me
hot we started on the show on a downbeat
and I told you next week is going to
shake the earth I would be at e3 next
week and we're getting III so to speak
in a way next week it's gonna be crazy
oh no it's cool Aries thanks for giving
us the heads up though no we definitely
we did we actually had a weird moment of
silence where we were just trying to
listen and I kept trying to have a
moment of silence that did not even
remotely happen if you can't hear your
clubs but I asked for a moment of
silence and I can't get it for a minute
and 13 seconds have you froze bungee to
give you though substantial content to
listen to you have to be played and
listen oh gosh out the Lord's a game and
died that day on that PlayStation 5
story babe let's be fresh well I worked
that night but man I hope that thing is
no that's busy why is that now featured
I want that on the top of the site dizzy
you're by CEO oh come on now that's huge
that these people will be talking about
that next week as well guys cuz while
this is a destiny podcast or gamers as
well so ks5 reveal has crazy stuff in it
we will discuss first time we've done
the last word like breaking news is good
or whatever we've this is we this is the
wrong time for news it never happens and
Friday morning more like this - four -
oh it happens when we get off right and
it'll be like 1:00 p.m. Eastern
oh yeah no whatever doesn't add until
about something this is huge yeah we got
we got the the pyramid Doritos mixtape
they just dropped a new mixtape they'd
have to do so I got that did we get the
PS 5 only here man first broken here
first or the last word this is awesome
it's live is live oh the video there's a
YouTube video if you go check it out in
like high-res it shows a crispy view of
the controller you actually get to see
the texture on the controller and the
buttons and everything let me see let me
see
here I'll drop it and chat it's just
slow yeah actually I see I see it yeah
so it's like a 16 second video just it's
more clear on YouTube cuz you can go my
RS mmm
let me retweet my guys man my guys are
working hard right now Lords of gaming
that nettle of y'all out here working
hard well this is what happens when
destiny has weird things happen
apparently it breaks our podcast but it
has been a fun one guys
I don't wrap it up because I feel like I
swear we're gonna like shut it down I'm
gonna do sir video than an hour later
there's gonna be a dusting and we're
back for podcast number two of the day
I'm gonna be like hugging you know wake
up wake up wake up wake up why are you
is least I'm going live see they're like
we got a bit something knows like it's a
lot of stuff to bubblin right now man
I'm feeling the excitement and fairly
excitement man we got ps5 reveal ps5 and
the launch games y'all launch games I
was gonna come out next week
wow this is lunch games yeah shout Lords
gaming that netzer all on bro come on
you gotta plug me now give me we got no
probably got cited by IGN I'm feeling
myself right now imma fulfill a little
height Hollywood shout-out to the Lord's
getting down there man we got actually
cited by window central PC gamer and
from for minecraft dungeon so we ought
to come up so yeah it looks like shout
to Jean looks like okay yeah it's gonna
be launched plans
own applause there it is yeah the clog a
gym shot to a gym dance wolf Ryan that's
why I'm excited to share that we will
soon give you your first look at the
games we play on PlayStation 5 launching
this holiday the games come to plea
expiration of firearms at the best in
the industry from the innovative studios
that span the
oh whoa then it says there's also a
rumored state of a play event in August
that will go into detail please for psvr
ps5 wow this is gonna be crazy man
shouted dramatic brother thanks for
stopping by this yeah this is can we at
least see what the console if I don't
know what the console looks like by
Friday I'm gonna flip my desk and this
thing's heavy so I really got between
now and then oh this is big are you
excited are you excited yeah like this
this is like gamer this is gamer
Christmas right now mm-hmm this gamers
Christmas is III and announcements and
new games and what's every general of
once every eight years or so we get to
enjoy a new console as well yep big man
good stuff good stuff he says no flippin
sir you're not gonna see what that thing
looks like they made I don't see they're
not gonna tell us the price cuz that's a
fight of chicken up until like November
like first it's still gonna be this game
of chicken and like blood Paul Tassie's
tweet the other day is like so like Jeff
Keeley is on stage between Phil Spencer
and Jim Ryun and they have to play
rock-paper-scissors and who tells their
price first yeah they definitely playing
a game of chicken on price oh it's no
doubt there's no doubt there's rumors
there's two different-sized hard drives
for the PS 5 I've seen that rumor out
there that there's like 825 meg 825 gig
versus the 1.6 terabyte which would
probably just be two of their SSDs for
price yeah oh the link you posted shows
some of that console oh okay they got a
little video place 85 game console with
playstation voice oh they got a vita
date is a youtube video i think that's
awesome that's concept i think that's
made as concept okay
I've seen some 40 Soleil this is old
I've seen that's very cool the fan made
stuff
yeah that's family stuff that ain't
anything no that's family family it's
cool but yeah there's there's you know
I've not seen anything official yet yeah
it's not official yet cuz I'm oh yeah we
apparently have gone off the rails here
today everybody to say the absolute
least but we probably should wrap up
this yes need podcast maybe no I agree
it has been a lot of fun though with you
guys this morning so if you do not
follow Bungie on Twitter do that that's
gonna be a good thing in the next yes
few days week twelve days however long
this crazy you know they're gonna drop
it in tires they're gonna drop an entire
CD before we get it if they go to 12
they're gonna have 12 tracks out there
one minute one pyramid ships out they're
dropping beats mm-hmm definite sup man
ah so we are we're gonna wrap up the
recording of course you guys know we
gotta send the love out there so if you
guys will hang on as we wrap up our
recording for the recording piece then
we're gonna send over the raid to send
some love out there so Oh
tell them what you got we'll try and
wrap this thing up cuz this is
ridiculous we ever so off the rails
right this off the road it's just so
many breaking news that jumped I know it
sounds sinister that came in late listen
majority no man law kognito on twitter i
lured podcast on Sunday we will have the
game by bostonians on man the wicked
gaming group man love these guys they
are so talented absolutely hilarious
they usually add us with packs we
usually meet them in the flesh these
guys a true gamer super telling do
shoutcasting they do they do everything
man these guys so tune in with gob
return my playstation 5 but I was gonna
talk about everything that's going on
with next gen Xbox everything man this
is a big Sunday so Sunday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern YouTube if you don't want to
catch on YouTube we're on Twitch we're
all mixer we're on Facebook iron Lords
podcast so just tune in some as a group
great group of guys we're doing that and
then also got to salute the Lords of
gaming down there man so proud of my
guys again fam a site made by the gamers
and dude we had a big week as far as
growth and as far as meeting recognized
and by our peers and I shout to IGN
who who sourced us shout out to UM
Windows central judge Gordon who sourced
us and shout out to also PC game a lot
of bigger outlets use that we've had our
first big break and I was very proud but
a guy shout the rage virus
he's also the big outriders fan but I
want to salute him and he all did a
fantastic job and all around our
editorial team and these guys work hard
and last but not least please on the
Isle of podcast YouTube channel please
support my brother King David she's
doing the king of statues this man has a
mausoleum of comic book and pop-culture
statues so if you're in there like
Marvel Comics DC Comics he's got a crazy
Colossus right now 90s x-men looks
amazing please support that and yeah man
please support the last word man try to
give you guys great content and we're
moving and grooving out here and I
shouted down yeah you seen the Colossus
it's awesome man but we really
appreciate the support and thanks for
rocking with us we do think he's gonna
have much to talk about that it was like
boom we speculated for a while and
things trickled in so yeah for me
honestly it's probably just gonna depend
on what destiny feels like dropping or
what I'm gonna be do I might be dabbling
into something else I got about you know
two weeks until June 19th The Last of Us
2 is definitely gonna be a priority when
that drops I'll be streaming that one
live on Twitch you guys of course keep
up with the content probably a season
review sunsetting discussion couple
videos that I got planned just to wrap
up the season but it is kind of like
waiting on the edge until I really say
anything else cuz if I say one thing the
next day crazy things changed maybe kind
of pointless so waiting to see what
happens for the time being but you guys
can find me twitch Twitter YouTube
subscribe alert bells for both of us
hit the subscription button and the
alert bells definitely helps us both cuz
YouTube is all sorts of crazy about that
stuff but it's been episode 105 May 29th
and we are almost to the Christmas of
gamers time in June so next week is
gonna be weird I don't know how long
next week's podcast gonna be honestly
it's gonna but we're gonna have plenty
to talk about and we will be working on
to guest for you guys as well
potentially lots to discuss so stay
tuned for that one follow us on the
Twitter's Maddy you guys there my
brother he said the best dad mom
Maddi without now humbled truly humbled
by that thank you
we're gonna go read I Lulu awesome just
really cool play alert yep so go send
her some love thank you guys very much
and for episode 105 May 29th it has been
the last word